there was something that really struck
me as I was listening to people talk
this morning 10 years ago if you had a
conference that was on capital and
liquidity two things would have been
notable one is everybody would have been
talking about Deposit Insurance and
nobody this morning mentioned to pause
insurance at all so that's a dramatic
change from what I think we would have
experienced any years ago and liquidity
probably wouldn't he even been on
anybody saw it so there really has been
quite a dramatic change in how people
are thinking about capital liquidity
systemic risk and so I thought from my
comments you were going to get plenty of
details about banking in Basel three
that I talked more about financial
stability more broadly which includes a
lot of the topics that we're talking
about today but it's not solely related
to what's going on in the banking sector
or with the supervisory requirements
that we have so let me start by talking
a little bit about financial stability
and I was going to start when I was
planning on coming out with my bound
copy of dodd-frank but it was too heavy
to carry in my carry-on and it was too
big and I think you're all quite aware
of how aluminous that legislation is but
I would say that well everybody agrees
that financial stability is very
important there is no clear definition
in the legislation so it's notable that
in all those pages and with so much
focused on how do we think about
financial stability we have an oversight
council that the legislators chose not
to actually define it and the reason
that's important is because I think
people define it differently and how you
define it does make a difference for how
you set regulations how you think about
the kinds of problems and how you think
about the possible policy responses so a
lot of the focus is on interconnected
failures and we had some discussion of
that this morning but what I want to
emphasize in my comments is it's not
just large institutions failing that can
create financial stability issues so I'm
going to talk a little bit about other
types of mechanisms some of them related
banking industry but not exclusively
related to the banking industry so let's
start with the definition so on the top
half this slide I've just put three
things that when you talk about
financial stability in common usage you
see that there are different ways of
interpreting what financial stability
means so sometimes when you hear people
talk about financial stability they seem
to be talking about volatility sometimes
they seem to be talking about clustered
failures of financial institutions
sometimes they are talking about asset
bubbles and how do we prevent asset
bubbles in the early stages of
development I'm gonna argue actually
that I wouldn't be focused on any of
those three in my own definition I'll
give you my definition in a minute and
so the definition we're using at the
Federal Reserve Bank of Boston but I do
think it is important because if I'm
focused on any one of those you might
come up with different policy
prescriptions about what supervisory
policy should do what regulatory policy
should do depending on which of these
things you really want to be focused on
so I do think it's important for us to
get a better sense when we're using
these kinds of terms what do we actually
mean so my definition I'll just focus on
financial instability you can all read
it but why don't I just quickly go over
financial instability occurs when
problems or concerns about potential
problems within institutions markets
payment system or the financial system
in general significantly impair the
supply of credit intermediation services
so as to substantially impact the
expected path of real economic activity
so what does that mean well I think it
breaks down into three elements the
first element is that you need to have a
problem in the financial system so I
think that's pretty intuitive but the
other two are critical as well one you
need a disruption or impairment of the
intermediation process so the supply of
credit is affected and finally you need
a substantial impact on the real economy
so why do we care so much about
financial intermediation this is
something that actually when I was going
to graduate school there was money in
banking at all the economics
than in many of the business schools and
actually the institutional knowledge
that's tied to money and banking and
financial markets virtually evaporated
over the last 20 years and it's actually
hard to get people outside of the
financial sector itself that really
understand a lot of the things that
we've been discussing today so
frequently if you're talking to an
academic and you're talking about Basel
3 you get a pretty blank stare unless
it's somebody and it's an unusual
academic who actually really understands
the mechanics of this they're in
relatively short supply I think that's
unfortunate this crisis has told us that
we actually need a better supply of
people coming out of our graduate
programs that have an appreciation for
this and so what normally would we talk
about for intermediating and why it's so
critical is that it plays a critical
transformation of assets and there are
two aspects to that one is the maturity
transformation and the other is the risk
transformation so people that are
providing deposits to a financial
intermediary frequently want to have
immediate access or close to immediate
access to their funds and when they want
to pull out their funds they don't want
their principal to be at risk but those
people who actually want the funds tend
to want the funds for a longer period of
time and tend to want to put it into
riskier assets so we have a natural
matching problem and that's why we have
financial intermediaries in the economy
to try to bridge this gap between
borrowing and lending and what we found
is that when that matching process gets
disrupted it has a really substantial
impact potentially on the economy and
can have significant macroeconomic
consequences Reinhart and Rogoff have a
very good book the kind of documents
some of the experiences over a very long
period of time with the kind of
disruptions that occur when we have
financial intermediation that becomes
broken and so I think it's much more
intuitive after going through the
financial crisis and I think that book
certainly documents some of the issues
about why that matching process is so
critical for a way
functioning economy and why when it gets
seriously disrupted you usually have a
very long recovery you usually have a
whole ting recovery and in fact that's
what we've been exhibiting so far is
that it's been a very slow and halt and
recovery that we've experienced today
now I want to highlight what's not in my
definition and that is that you don't
necessarily have to have failures of
institutions in order to have
significant disruptions that's certainly
a way that you can have it but it's not
a requirement so even if no individual
institution fails even if no group of
institutions fail you could still have
financial stability being seriously
compromised and one of the things that I
want to highlight is you care about the
substitutability of this intermediary
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
that in a couple of examples in a minute
but the intermediary services if
somebody can immediately step in and do
the same thing costlessly then I
wouldn't have to be all that worried
about intermediation getting disrupted
but if they're very poor substitutes so
that we can't easily transfer that
matching to another organization then
that can be a real problem for the
economy and so I think it's important to
think about what is the substitute
ability of the intermediary services I
would also highlight what's not in my
definition is just asset bubbles that's
not to say that asset bubbles can't
create a financial stability problem
they can but not all asset bubbles are
sources of financial instability a
critical component of whether or not it
becomes financial instability is what is
the role of leveraged financial
intermediaries so of leveraged financial
intermediaries have a very large
exposure to that asset then potentially
if the value of that asset declines
quite rapidly it has a broader impact on
the intermediating process so when we
think about asset bubbles and whether
it's having an impact on financial
instability
we have to ask what are the role of the
intermediaries in the economy how is it
being financed what is the likelihood
that similar organizations have the same
exposure but when I think about
financial instability it's not
synonymous with talking about asset
in the economy now I'm going to talk
about three things first of all that I
think are not examples of financial
instability and then I'm going to talk
about three examples that I do think a
better financial instability just to
give a sense of what I'm trying to
convey by this definition and then I'll
have some concluding remarks so the
three that I'm going to argue are not
instances of financial instability or
some recent experience with silver
prices the failures the grouped failures
of Savings and Loan institutions and the
experience that we had with the dot-com
problem earlier last decade so let's
start with silver prices its silver
prices are actually kind of interesting
if you look back to the late 70s it was
a period when there was an attempt to
try to corner the market and silver and
as you can see there was a very rapid
increase in silver prices it was not a
completely successful attempt to corner
the market and silver so there was also
a very rapid decrease in silver prices
that happened shortly thereafter you can
then see that we had a long period where
people were where silver prices didn't
really move very much at all and then
very recently we've had a very big
run-up in a number of commodity prices
both precious metals but also other
types of commodities but more recently
there was a relatively rapid decline in
the silver prices so this is an example
of something that has a lot of price
volatility but I would argue that
there's nothing in the silver market
that would make me worried about
financial instability so why would I say
that this price volatility is not
synonymous with financial instability
well one it's a relatively small market
so while some people took a big risk in
the commodity market it wasn't widely
held and particularly it wasn't widely
held in financial intermediaries that
were highly levered so it wasn't really
financed by highly levered institutions
it's a small enough market that even if
the price goes down doesn't have a huge
wealth effect in the economy overall and
doesn't really affect GDP unemployment
the kinds of macroeconomic very
that we would care about so even though
it is very volatile this would not be
something that I'd be particularly
concerned about with my financial
instability definition let's turn next
to what happened with the Savings & Loan
industry so this was a situation where
there were clustered failures and so
it's not that the problem of the Savings
& Loan industry was not a problem
it certainly was we had a Deposit
Insurance Scheme that was extremely
costly and wasn't structured
appropriately and we had regulatory and
supervisory oversight of savings and
loans that was inappropriate
particularly for the monetary policy
that we were running at the time so if
you recall the savings and loans were in
a situation where they were borrowing
funds and investing in long term
mortgages at a time when interest rates
went up very rapidly that was partly a
result of regulation and supervision
partly a result of choice so there's a
combined culpability there but they as a
result of for the most part supervisory
forbearance the full impact of those
losses weren't realized immediately we
had net worth certificates in a variety
of other different mechanisms to avoid
closing down savings and loans
particularly rapidly and you can see it
took quite a while before we really saw
widespread failures of savings and loans
so while there were a lot of failures of
financial institutions and while it was
very costly for the taxpayer why would I
say this isn't necessarily an instance
of financial instability well this shows
you the cost relative to the 10-year
Treasury yield of getting a 30-year
fixed mortgage which is what the savings
and loans were primarily focused on and
you can see shadowed is the the failures
and what's notable is that you're not
seeing much of a disruption in the
funding of mortgages at a time when we
had an awful lot of failures so why is
that well this is a case where there was
a lot of substitutability
between the Savings and Loan industry
and other types of financial
intermediaries commercial banks savings
banks the securitization market was
picking up
so in terms of a borrower if I wanted to
buy a house and borrow money in order to
buy that house the fact that the Savings
and Loan industry was having a lot of
difficulties didn't really impair the
cost of credit and didn't really impair
the ability to get credit and so again
while there was a widespread failure of
savings and loans and it was very
unfortunate we could have done a much
better job with the regulation
supervision I would not call this period
of financial instability because it
didn't have a big impact on the real
economy because there was a lot of
substitutability between financial
intermediaries for this type of
financial product next let's turn to the
internet and the bubble that we had or
the presumed bubble that we had at the
end of the 90s and beginning of the last
decade and as you can see there was a
very rapid increase in dot-com stock
prices that shortly thereafter all also
fell something I don't have to say to
this audience but I would highlight that
I again this actually was more
widespread it did have an impact on the
economy
it was mostly through a wealth effect
but wealth effects are something that we
are actually pretty capable of
addressing through more traditional
monetary policy and I would argue in
this case that despite the the rapid
increase in decrease in prices here this
was not a situation where most the
financing was financed by highly levered
institutions
it was mostly equity finance so it did
impact wealth but it did not impact the
financial intermediation process as a
result we had a very different issue
coming out of this recession than we did
over the Great Recession okay so let let
me next go to examples where there is
financial instability and again I think
a lot of focus on dodd-frank has been on
large too-big-to-fail type of
organizations but I want to highlight in
this talk is there lots of other ways
that you can get financial instability
and so the first
example I'm going to talk about is the
experience of the money market mutual
funds during the crisis because I think
there's been an under waiting of how
important that has been for the
disruptions of short-term credit during
the crisis and that really was the
smallest institution is the biggest risk
rather than the largest institution so
it kind of turns dodd-frank on its head
in terms of it's not too big to fail
it's too small to be able to address the
problem and so I want to talk a little
bit about that second I want to talk
about risk of widely held exposures that
may not involve failure at all and in
that I'm going to talk about in effect
credit crunches where a financial
institution doesn't have to fail in
order to have a problem in the
intermediate process that could impact
the real economy and then finally I'll
talk a little bit about the
interconnectedness so this shows you the
daily change in money market mutual fund
assets at prime money market funds so
there are three types of money market
funds you have the government only kind
of money market fund you have ones that
are tax-exempt and then you have the
prime money market funds which are able
to invest in a wider group of assets
which tend to include commercial paper
asset backed commercial paper bankers
acceptances and you can see that after
Lehman failed one of the consequences of
the Lehman failure was that the reserve
primary fund didn't have the capacity to
meet the obligations of not breaking the
buck in other words maintaining a stable
net asset value which is what the money
market funds promised to their investors
and as a result there became concerned
not only at the reserve fund but also at
a wide variety of other money market
funds so there was a rapid movement out
of money market funds and then and I'm
going to show you another slide that
shows you one of the places that it
moved but I would just highlight that
those are pretty big numbers and these
are days and so day by day having
hundreds of billions of dollars leaving
a financial intermediary even if you
have a lot of liquidity and even if the
duration of these are fairly short those
kind of very rapid movements are
to be a problem for any kind of
financial intermediary as long as
there's any transformation of the asset
at all so it's not surprising that they
had a very significant problem and in a
part had to be addressed by government
intervention so there was insurance
provided by the Treasury during the
crisis for an organization that
everybody had assumed was not going to
get insurance and there was also
liquidity facility actually run by the
Federal Reserve Bank of Boston which was
focused on two components how do we make
sure that the asset backed commercial
paper market doesn't get completely
disrupted and I'll show you a slide on
that in a minute but also though to try
to staunch the flow out of the money
market fund industry and you can see
that with the Fed announcement of the
AML F as well as the start of the
insurance program within a couple of
weeks we started to have a more stable
situation in the money market fund
industry I would also highlight that at
the same time the New York Fed was very
active and a whole variety of other
programs to try to deal with the
disruption that was happening to
short-term credit markets so one of the
concerns was the people that were
pulling their funds out but from a
systemic standpoint you care about the
asset side as well as the liability side
of the balance sheet so on the asset
side the concern was acid back
commercial paper commercial paper
bankers acceptances all of a sudden
there was a very large investor and
those type of assets that was not
willing to buy those assets because they
were having to quickly get funds
available to take care of redemptions so
it was a situation that immediately
required attention and you can see that
one of the things that occurred so the
the purple which is the bottom is the
prime money market funds that I was just
illustrating you can see the green which
were the taxable government's was where
an awful lot of the organization's moved
so you got out of the prime money market
fund you could easily transfer usually
within the same fund family into
government only during a crisis
governments actually tend to do pretty
well the risk was actually quite small
and the default risk was negligible and
you can see that there was a very rapid
increase
that green bar as we got into the fall
of 2008 so there was a natural shift
that was occurring in the types of money
markets but it'll also highlighted why
it's so easy to run because these are
funds that you can pull out immediately
and you could easily pull it into
another account quite easily that didn't
have the same attributes as the one that
you were in so what kind of disruptions
did that occur
well this focuses on the asset back
commercial paper market but I think you
can see a similar type of pattern if you
look at the other kinds of financial
assets the money market funds held and
so the first thing to note is that I'm
showing the spread relative to the
effect of Fed Funds rate and there was a
very dramatic increase in the cost of
funding for asset backed commercial
paper but perhaps even more importantly
is the maturity structure so the share
of asset backed commercial paper
maturing in one to four days went up to
90 percent so basically if you wanted
any kind of longer-term financing it
wasn't available in the market and
that's not only for this market it was
true for a wide variety of other markets
so there was a real serious disruption
in short-term credit markets that I
think clearly made it systemic so in
that case we had a very small money
market fund that was not able to live up
to the expectations of a stable asset
value and as a result of its inability
to make those payments caused a broader
run that disrupted the cost of financing
and the availability of financing and I
would argue had a big impact on the real
economy as well so money market funds I
do think are something that are
critically important for financial
stability and actually not addressing
that is a financial instability that we
actually want to worry about and so I
want to just talk about that because
while there were very substantial things
done by the SEC and I think those are
welcomed in terms of thinking about the
duration of the assets thinking about
the liquidity of the money market funds
the basic problem with the reserve fund
was there was a credit risk so there was
at least one money market fund and
actually quite a few money market funds
that had men
is the credit risk of potential Lehmann
failure and so that credit risk is what
actually caused the problem and so I
think the risk is that that has not been
addressed in any of the regulatory
changes this is two and a half years
after the crisis and the money market
fund situation is basically in terms of
the credit risk very similar to what we
were encountering during the fall of
2008 and I would highlight that there is
a vulnerability here so money market
funds are looking to have a higher yield
and one of the ways of getting higher
yield right now is to invest in short
term at debt instruments in Europe so
they do have an exposure to European
banks for example and as we're all aware
there are some issues going on in Europe
right now so there is a potential risk
I'm not expecting necessarily to have a
bad outcome but nonetheless it is a
vulnerability that I think that we have
to be aware of similarly taking it from
the perspective of the Europeans a
critical source of short-term dollar
financing for the European banks is the
money market fund industry so we have a
pairing here that is a systemic
vulnerability the money market funds
have some risk to unexpected credit loss
in Europe and the European financial
institutions have a risk that could even
just be a regulatory change that causes
the money market funds not to want to
hold short-term debt instruments in
European institutions so I think this is
a situation that deserves a fair bit of
attention so what are the possible
solutions well there are a number of
solutions that have been recommended
some of them are on this slide allowing
the asset value of funds to float so
instead of promising net asset value
that's fixed allowing there to be some
variation a second is that you require
the money market funds to have capital
so that if there is a loss they have the
capacity to actually meet the cost
the third is potentially requiring a
source of strength so a ma money market
fund that has no capacity to finance
some bad assets in the
folio maybe that is not acceptable maybe
you want a source a strength or maybe
you want to require some kind of
insurance bond or there are a number of
different financial mechanisms that you
could actually a doc so they've been a
number of solutions that have been
suggested I would highlight that none of
the solutions are very far down the path
right now and I think that's unfortunate
what does a solution need well I think
there three components one is it has to
address the impact of an unexpected
credit loss we at least need to be able
to handle the last crisis and if we
can't even handle the last crisis that
is a potential problem second we have to
deal with the incentive for investors to
move funds quite quickly particularly
when there frequently is an alternative
that may be very easy to do which is
moving into a government only money
market fund and the third is there is an
operational convenience to money market
funds which is because there's a stable
net asset value every time I write a
check on my money market fund I don't
have to have a capital gain or a capital
loss so if you used it as a transaction
account you wrote hundreds of checks
though most people aren't writing checks
anymore but if you were one of those
people writing hundreds of checks then
if it wasn't a stable net asset value
have all these capital gains and capital
losses so thinking about how we address
the problem in a way that continues to
have the transaction account vehicle is
a component that I think that the money
market fund industry is very concerned
about but I think despite the various
challenges with getting a solution this
is a vulnerability that continues it is
a vulnerability that I think it's very
important for us to address and I'm
hoping that we'll have more of a
discussion over time to think about what
is the best way forward the second
financial instability I want to talk
about is a banking example and in this
example I'm going to focus not on banks
that have failed but just banks that
have become troubled so in this slide
I'm looking at the first year of the
recession and asking what is the
difference between institutions with
high camels ratings so the camels
ratings gets at capital assets
management earnings liquidity and
sensitivity to market risk and so if you
have a 1 or 2 it means you have a low
probably
failure if you have a thigh that means
that failure is more than likely
imminent so three four and five are the
more troubled institutions not a perfect
comparison for capital constrained but
actually some of the research which I've
done in the past has indicated that it
isn't a bad indicator of capital
constraints by and large and you can see
that while none of these banks were
failed banks there was a difference in
behavior between those banks that got
trouble and started to reduce lending
and those banks that were not troubled
now that's very logical if you have a
binding capital asset ratio there are a
number of ways to address that one is
you can increase capital we'll have a
discussion of how costly it is to raise
capital later this afternoon
but assuming that at least if the banks
think it's costly to raise capital so
they're not particularly willing to do
that then the other way that you meet a
capital asset ratio is your shrink
assets while shrinking assets is
reducing the intermediating process for
the rest of the economy so problems that
the banks have an impact on the
borrowers of those banks doesn't require
a bank failure doesn't require a Lehman
Brothers in order for this to happen and
so in the early 1990s we had a situation
like that arguably right now we still
have a situation where there many
capital constrained banks particularly
in some parts of the country that have a
disproportionate amount of real estate
losses both residential and commercial
real estate so this just shows you what
the pattern of real CNI loans have been
and I would highlight one thing
all right highlight a couple of things
actually one is that the decline in real
CNI loans has been pretty appreciable
during the most the Great Recession in
the recovery from the Great Recession
but the other is each of these
recessions have been very slow
recoveries so the previous two were
called jobless recoveries we didn't get
much of a recovery and interestingly
enough it's coincident with their not
being very rapid increase in CNI lending
and I do think in the most recent crisis
there has been a very substantial
decrease in credit at least in part by
organizations trying to meet their
capital ratios by shrinking some of
their assets and this just provides
another way of looking at it with
is from the borrowers what is the cost
what are the standards that are
occurring and you can see in this Great
Recession we have had a period where
there was a very substantial increase in
the tightening standards of the banking
industry as they ran into some
difficulties so the third example is one
I think is well understood which is the
Lehman Brothers the the very large
institution that fails and gets at
interconnectedness there is a number of
ways to think about interconnectedness
the first is kind of the immediate
exposure of the firm so while we may not
know who the creditors - Lehman were we
at least know one of them was the
reserve fund and through the bankruptcy
proceedings we're learning about what
the exposures of lots of other
organizations were but normally we don't
know who the immediate what the
immediate impact of the organizations
that have a credit exposure that isn't
public information so that's one source
of interconnectedness a second is and it
got to one of the questions that was
asked earlier yes the counterparty
exposures are not well known and so
there is no Paik miss and that you don't
really know what the counterparties are
to a particular organization that you
think is getting deeply into trouble and
that was one of the factors that caused
the spread between the one month LIBOR
rate and the overnight index swap rate
to really grow very substantially during
the crisis banks were even concerned
about evaluating some of their largest
peers so when this first appeared it was
really quite dramatic that some of the
largest banks in the world were
unwilling to lend for one month or
sometimes even one day to some of their
peers that they just didn't have a
degree of comfort that they could really
ascertain what the credit risk was and
what the potential impact on them would
be of an unsecured position the two
other components of interconnectedness
one is the criticality of the firm so
many of these firms service market
makers and particularly critical markets
and so we don't want that kind of
intermediary disrupted auction rate
securities and a variety of other
markets were disrupted when some
large financial institutions that were
very critical to those markets got into
trouble and then the increasing global
nature of the large financial
intermediaries we haven't had a lot
discussing kind of resolution and the
difficulties with resolution but the
International component remains a very
big challenge how do we address a very
large organization what does that mean
for interconnectedness when it's not
only a domestic and/or connectiveness
but a global interconnectedness and that
even makes it more difficult to
understand what the patterns of a
potential failure would be now I think
there are a lot of questions to explore
they're a bunch of academics in this
room this is an area that I think
actually is fairly unexplored area and I
think we have to do an awful lot more
work here so one is just how do we
measure interconnectedness I don't think
there right now is a good way even if
you have access to confidential
information how do you actually come up
with a good measure of
interconnectedness if you can come up
interconnectedness how should that
affect capital requirements what does
that mean for how much you want to
reduce the probability that a highly
interconnected firm becomes insolvent
and then we get to the disclosure so
banks are monitoring their counterparty
risk how much should be revealed to
supervisors at a matter of course how
much should be revealed more generally
to the market if interconnectedness is
an important component of systemic
concern then maybe there's a reason for
the public at large to have some sense
of how interconnected a firm is and
finally what kind of role can
stress-test play so the Federal
Reserve's gone through to stress tests
over the last couple of years one of the
things that we've been asking is about
counterparty exposures and I do think
that there's probably room to think
about how do we use stress test more
effectively to think about this
interconnectedness problem that is more
likely to be something that we saw I
don't know if we solve that we can at
least better understand through stress
testing than maybe through other
mechanisms so just some very brief
concluding remarks and then I'll be able
to answer some questions I think the
concept of financial stability means
different things to different people I
actually think that we have to settle
what a definition of financial stability
is so that we understand what are the
problems that we're trying to address
I've suggested my own definition which
is the definition we're using at the
Federal Reserve Bank of Boston as we
talk about financial stability and what
we should be doing but I think that we
need to get a more widespread agreement
on what financial stability is what my
nancial stability isn't and then I think
it really highlights there's a lot more
work to be done
understanding what really causes
impairment of financial intermediaries
and how that impairment of financial
intermediaries can affect a broader
economy is something that I think is not
particularly well understood it doesn't
fit into our macro model so during the
financial crisis as we were trying to
think about what is the effect of
financial intermediaries virtually all
our macro models don't model this
particularly well and so it is a real
problem from any of the central banks
it's a problem for private regulators
and so I think it's a real challenge to
really get a better understanding of how
this kind of financial stability issue
plays out more generally so that
concludes my remarks and I'd be glad to
answer some questions
I want to ask you about the money market
fund so you talked about the question is
with respect to liquidity demanded by
individuals and check-writing and all of
that
we have deposit insurance and there's a
goes to what 250,000 whatever goes
through the question is does do we need
a safety net system sort of for
check-writing beyond that and what's
this sort of total cost benefit of sort
of having floating net asset value do we
know for sure that you know people need
the buck guaranteed I'm asking for
myself but for example I just read this
weak proposal by by Kansas Fed which
which specifically says that the
recommend is a way to handle for example
shadow banking specifically removing the
any kind of guarantee so the original
concept of the money market funds was in
effect the old narrow Bank which is
there going to hot hold very short term
assets of very high quality and that as
a result they're going to be able to
have a stable asset and what wasn't
taken into account
we're tale events and the fact that to
the extent that you're taking any kind
of credit risk there is a potential that
the net asset value is going to change
so one possible solution would be to
think about extending the insurance to
those organizations that doesn't sound
like what's likely to occur my sense is
that Congress is not anxious to extend
the the safety net to money market funds
and impart money market funds originally
were created as a capital arbitrage so
it was a structure that didn't require
capital banks did have capital and so
there was an arbitrage in effect from
the banking industry to the money market
fund industry to avoid capital
requirements so when we talk about what
are some of the distortionary effects of
capital requirements this is one of the
examples this is an industry created out
of a capital Distortion
so I'm not sure the solution I would
choose at least would be to extend the
safety net to these organizations but I
so and I don't think there's much public
policy support for extending this to
money market funds
what would I personally do what I would
personally do would probably be a
combination of both a capital
requirement and floating nav and a
floating nav by itself doesn't solve the
problem and the reason for that is you
still have an incentive to run you don't
know what the exposures are and so just
imagine if you were in a money market
fund on the day that the reserve fund
announced that they had an exposure to
Lehman you don't have any idea whether
your money market fund has exposure to
Lehman you're not going to wait to find
out you're going to transfer the funds
as quickly as you can so even with a
floating rate nav you don't eliminate
the risk of very rapid movement out of
that fund so I think you actually need a
combination of things that would be my
own personal view Eric I wanted to go
back to one of your earlier slides when
you talked about some of the key roles
the bags play in society one of which
being the transformation this morning we
talked about a number of firms Mipham
own firms like this we learned a lot
from this crisis how precious liquidity
was and that that was one of the key
things to her own solvency and her own
safety and now we're also building a lot
of regulations around to
institutionalize that among a number of
other institutions wonder how you
balance the issue of if all firms are
racing to kind of keep their own rainy
day liquidity funds and lessen the
amount of maturity transformation what
that does the supply of this to the
overall economy and how you balance that
macro issue of supplying key service to
the economy with a Prudential issue of
all firms now trying to take the lesson
of this crisis and be be more safe so I
think that's a really good question and
I don't think we have a good way of
quantifying actually exactly what the
costs are if we're
wiring too much or potentially too
little liquidity our models aren't
particularly good at calibrating that I
do think we have had an example of what
can happen when we have too little
liquidity and we found those costs are
actually pretty large or at least
potentially pretty large the cost of
society I mean if everybody was a money
market fund and somebody wants to borrow
for a home or for other types of
business investments you know money
market funds not a vehicle that's going
to give you a long-term financing for a
business so there is a natural problem
with any kind of financial intermediary
and part of what makes them valuable is
this transformation process and it's a
public policy balancing act to say what
is the appropriate amount of capital
what's the appropriate amount of
liquidity and we can push too too much
in either direction I think we're moving
in the direction of getting that balance
more right than we had during the
process but I think it remains to be
seen whether we go too far or whether we
don't go far enough and hopefully over
time we'll get a better idea of how well
to calibrate our models so that we have
a better sense so there was an argument
earlier that we needed rafael
highlighted what are the costs and
benefits of this regulatory policy I
agree with that but it's not that easy
to do and so one of the challenges is if
you require everybody to be extremely
liquid it means a lot of the
transformation doesn't occur so I think
that is something we have to work on I
don't think we have a good way of
modeling so you talked about
interconnectedness across financial
institution I want to talk about a
slightly different internet
connectedness that's come up in the
press and that is when the government is
virtual and debt that then the financial
institutions need to hold to meet their
reserve requirements and more and more
of the government debt is not going to
necessarily into the real economy so to
speak it's going into debt service so
how do we I mean
you've thought about this issue or how
do you think about the
interconnectedness with
that kind of government debt funding
through some called it repression but
through the the ability to require
reserves held in government paper in
fact and what does that do to these
financial institutions as they're trying
to sort out their ability to get what we
didn't stay with would and the price of
that
so certainly government securities are
one of the assets that banks are going
to hold and both the liquidity
requirements and the risk weighted
assets are providing an encouragement to
purchase what are at least from a
default sense or at least we presume
from a default sense for the US
government low if not zero default risk
and so our banking regulations do have
an encouragement to hold that asset but
it's more because of the characteristic
of the asset but because it doesn't have
a default risk that that is the one type
of asset that during the crisis it
clearly was able to be converted into
cash for institutions that needed to
raise cash so I think there's a logic to
why we have in some sense encouraged
government securities holdings we
wouldn't want to over encourage that so
we certainly want the transformation of
assets you want institutions to be
taking credit risk you want institutions
to be offering financing for longer-term
maturities so that is an important part
of getting the private sector financed
so I don't know if that addresses your
question quieter I'm just wondering what
flexibility there is within the reserve
requirement to to diversify somehow from
so you talk about the reserve
environment specifically yeah this
probably get more technical than I'm
going to talk about right now but so the
Treasury securities are different than
the reserve requirement and the quantity
of reserves in the
system is more tied to the Federal
Reserve's balance sheet then the
composition of assets being held by the
banks but rather than going into a
torturous description maybe we could
talk offline and I can talk more about
that